hi I'm Rhea and this is my recipe for
animal boiled eggs so my mom used to
make me rubbish shaped boiled egg when I
was a little when I started walking for
pasty Japan I wanted to recreate so I
asked my mom how she made it and she
sent me a picture but it was very show
and simple so I made it four different
ways and there is a term for cue bento
called the Caliban which is like
character bento
so my mom used to make me bento
throughout my high school days I think
Japanese mom likes make bento really
cute so kids enjoy more to eat
so the sesame seeds and Carol I added
not for the taste they are just for
decoration it's also a trick make food
cute and keeps it there no favorite food
but foods that are important for them to
eat so the Hedgehog you can also use
knife but I use a straw because that can
be less intimidating this is one of the
very first video I made I think this has
been done for a long time because when I
made this video my dad also told me his
mother also used to make this for him it
may seems like a lot of work to just
alter something that will be the same
food but I think it's worth it it's
really just cutting edge into cue
animals so I tested a bunch of different
animals using same technique and I
wanted to make a variety of animals not
just rabbit the reason I used
hard-boiled egg it's just because my mom
used to make this way but you don't need
to use hard boiled egg just use anything
available in your country and make it
cute be creative
q and kawaii animals is a universal
language so I think kids all over the
world would appreciate having this in
their lunches it seems like audience in
the US and also international audience
really enjoy this video because this was
translated to different pages like
Brazilians Germans French and Latin
America page on
60 they all seems to like it a lot and a
curry is available in any countries
I really appreciate my mom make effort
to make my lunch very cute and I think
children to universal and food is also
universal I think all the kids around
the world enjoy
cuteness in their lunchbox I know it's
time-consuming but it's really fun and
cute just give a try once in a while
make it cute thank you all for watching
this again and this is my last video
just kidding this is just the last video
we are shooting today well be sure to
send your own animal creation to my ears
around my hand relates to the slob I
want to see your animal eggs and other
stuff ok I see you all later
well let's do one more time for the
ending
[Music]